Charlie Hunnam talks 50 shades of grey  while Chris Evans jumps out of a plane  the stunt wasn't for Captain America but  for Esquire magazine inside Evans  reveals he's been skydiving before with  his ex-girlfriend Jessica Biel the two  dated on and off from 2001 to 2006 but  he's not commenting on his most recent  ex Jenny slate quote I'm steering clear  of those questions meanwhile Charlie  Hunnam still hasn't seen Fifty Shades of  Grey I don't know whether to worship at  your feet  where's thank you Charlie was originally  cast for Jamie Jordan's role as  Christian Grey but back out due to  scheduling conflicts I'm just so excited  to be you know entrusted with this you  know really powerful character and and  you know and just really excited me get  to get to filming and stuff you know  bringing him to life  he tells Elle magazine quote that was a  somewhat traumatic experience for me I  didn't want to open that wound  [Music]